so welcome to the first session of this
year's key IP which is also the first
plenary talk featuring the best best
student paper and I want to mention that
the award will be presented on Thursday
and a conference dinner I believe a
Wednesday sorry on Wednesday and the
conference ting relief okay so this talk
will be about very cool cryptographic
primitive called Hanafi encryption for
quantum data and in my opinion this is
probably one of the most exciting
advances in quantum cryptography in the
past year and this work was done by
folks from University of Amsterdam
if cadelec christian Schaffner and
Floren Spielman and i will be presenting
this work just let you know well I wish
I could the authors wouldn't be happy so
uh actually Thorin will be our speaker
and this talk itself will be 15 minutes
and after then you have a few minutes
for questions and let's let's welcome
flurry
right so thanks for the introduction and
thanks for the opportunity to speak here
so okay so I will be talking about
quantum homomorphic encryption with
called my co-author Zarif Kahoot was
pictured there on the left and Chris
which picture there on the right Chris
is also present here at PRP and they are
researches in Amsterdam and for most of
this work I was also a PhD students in
Amsterdam although recently I started to
postdoc in in Copenhagen all right so
what is fun homomorphic encryption we
will have the same protagonists we often
have mainly Ellis and Ellis is it's on
holidays and honor holidays she sees
many interesting things for example she
takes a photo of a coffee shop I so this
is for example the original Starbucks
and she takes a photo of some other
interesting landmark and now when she
when she gets home she might want to
categorize his photos so she might want
to attack them so maybe she wants to
write for the first photo she wants to
write cafe and for the second she wants
to write Space Needle but you know now
she only took two photos but maybe she
has a huge album and it's it's a lot of
work to tag them all so she might want
some help but on her travels she also
encounters a friendly cloud so this this
cloud says I have a computer I have some
spare processing power i've servers in
my you know floating around somewhere
and i can help you take these photos i
have a sophisticated tagging algorithm
that i trained on huge data sets so you
know just send me the photos and i'll
i'll give them tags but alice is a
little bit suspicious because she
doesn't just want to send off her photos
to some you know some talking cloud she
doesn't know what his motivations are
exactly so actually she's going to do
something a bit more sophisticated than
just send off these photos she's going
to encrypt these photos
and then she's going to send these
encrypted photos off to the cloud and
now the the kind of metric trick about
quantum homomorphic encryption is that
now this cloud computer is able to
perform a computation on these encrypted
photos without decrypting them in the
mean time so from the perspective of
this cloud these fold this data will
always be encrypted so it starts just
you know from the perspective of clouds
that cloud it looks like a mess it's
looks encrypted and then he he can still
perform a computation and get encrypted
outcome and now he can send back this
encrypted outcome which can be decrypted
by LS so she can you know get the the
information that she wants it's so you
know the disk can help lots right so now
the clay now the privacy of Alice is it
safe and actually for a long time
cryptographers would really I really
wanted to do this but they didn't know
how so people thought maybe it's even
impossible but in a breakthrough results
in 2009 Gentry proposed a protocol or
came up with a protocol which which does
this for classical data and of course
here we had q IP so we would like to
think you know what happens if instead
of Alice taking photos she you know she
takes quantum photos or she has some
quantum quantum data and she would like
to send out this quantum data to to some
cloud computer some other server and
would like you know would like this
server should be able to do computations
on this data without compromising
alice's privacy so and this talk is
about the quantum case of this problem
so first I'll I'll spend some time being
a bit more careful to define you know
what what is in how morphic encryption
scheme what do we want out of it then
I'll present some some basic proposals
that don't quite work and then of course
I'll say what we have to do to extend
this to to come up with a better scheme
so just as a basic thing what are the
ingredients of a homomorphic encryption
scheme so of course if you have an
encryption scheme you will have some key
generation protocol so Ellis will have
her computer generates say a public key
which which can be used to encrypt data
a secret key which can be used to
decrypt and some other and some extra
dates at which which is there for
technical reasons which is called an
evaluation key now encryption just means
she takes the public key takes her data
say the photograph and encrypts it and
of course we would like some notion of
security so from the perspective of
someone that doesn't know any key this
should look completely or this should
look completely indistinguishable from
some other photo or maybe even a black
picture so you shouldn't be able to
learn anything about about the data and
what makes homomorphic encryption
special is this evaluation procedure so
which is run by the cloud computer in
this case so the innovation procedure
takes some encrypted data the evaluation
key and some computer program that you
want to run so it might be the
proprietary image tagging algorithm from
the from the class computer and take
those together and then produce the
encrypted outputs and of course there's
a decryption algorithm that takes the
private key and the encrypted data and
gets back the results so the LS should
also be able to get it back and of
course this should work for any general
classical base I'll show you should
should give know so if if we just talk
about some data X and then we want to
run some program on this data X take the
computer program or a Turing machine a
circuit and now about could and so this
was the case of a soft and in the
quantum case we want to do something
similar right so LS has now some quantum
steps I I will just talk about pure
States but of course there's no reason
why why Dahl should be pure States just
to make the notation simpler
and then and then this evaluation key in
our case we also allow to be quantum so
then we we have some more technical
tricks we can use with the simulation
key is consumable and now instead of
some function we want to apply we just
say we would like to scheme to apply
some unitary alright so what has been
done before or at least look at let's
look at some things that we can try so
first let's think about some some
trivial things we we may be able to try
so and then just see you know what what
do we want out of the scheme so let's
say the most silly scheme possible and
let's just takes our input sends it off
and then ask the computation to be
performed so of course this is not
encryption but you know but this is how
more the homomorphic property that we
want out of a scheme ya know it's
satisfied and there will also be some
other property called compactness that i
will explain in a minute but of course
this scheme is not secure at all right
LS LS your data is just in the public so
we might think well let's just encrypt
this data in some way and let's see what
we can do there so the most basic
encryption scheme for quantum data is
the quantum one-time pad which is a
quantum analog of the of the classical
one-time pad and it's and it basically
works as follows
you pick a random classical data and
that two classical bits and then
depending on these classical bits apply
a poly to the quantum state so for
example this like if Alice would just
encrypt your data send it off then it's
secure again but now we have no idea how
to perform a computation on data which
is encrypted with a one-time pad so of
course this also won't work and there's
also a slightly more interesting trivial
scheme which which doesn't work that we
can try and that is we encrypt the data
with a one-time pad send it off and then
the cloud computer just says I'll just
append my program codes to this to this
encrypted data send it back and now we
define our description procedure
first decrypt the data and then run this
program of course this is a very silly
thing to do but but there's this other
requirement of the scheme that we have
which is called compactness and it means
that the decryption procedure should be
equally hard no matter what circuit is
applied to this data so this kind of
trivial scheme breaks that property
because now if the server would append a
very long circuit and ask to ask the
decryption procedure to apply that then
of course the decryption procedure would
take a very long time so these are the
things that don't you know that we don't
want out of a scheme and we want to come
up with a scheme that then that's good
in all these respects so it is actually
possible to build a nice scheme without
too much effort for a limited class of
circuits called the clifford circuits so
so earlier work came up with scheme for
this and here we so the Clifford
circuits are like a subset of all
quantum computations and well here
instead of perfect security like for the
one time that it will be computational
security but I'll explain what I mean
with that in a second so what are these
Clifford circuits so the Clifford group
is are just those quantum operations
generated by applying Hadamard guides
the phase guides and C notes and these
these circuits have very nice properties
but the one that we care about right now
is that applying these gates poly
operators to poly operators the
commutation rules for these these
operations work very nicely with the
police so for example hadam are times
the poly X equals Z times Z gate times
ahead of Mario I'm just ignoring global
faces for now because we're we're just
applying everything is gate so we don't
care about what faces there will be some
some minus signs in these these
relations actually and it's the same for
for for example the phase gate and also
for the cenote gate now it's for example
the C not
apply two extensors I kind of copies the
DiPaola x2 the other bit from the from
the control bit to the target so it
doesn't really matter what these rules
are it's just matters for our case that
it that they exist there is some simple
way of of you know if we have a
computation swapping the order of a poly
and a Clifford gate but of course the
Clifford gates do not form a universal
gate set so for example the circuits
jessica system of these gates can be
efficiently simulated classically but
also just by counting you can see
there's way fewer of these then then
there are off of general quantum units
Ares alright but let's now see what what
you do to build a scheme for just these
guys so our ingredient one will be the
quantum one-time pad again so our
encryption like we seen before is we
pick two classical bits and I'll just
write them with like an icon to remind
us that with the key that this is the
key for the one-time pad and then we use
these classical bits to apply a pal
apply DiPaola to the to the bits we want
the qubit we want to encrypt and I'll
write a lock to remind us that these
pile is really represents an encryption
and then decryption is just applying the
same parties again to get rid of them
and our second ingredient will be to use
classical homo 'fuck encryption so we
can just use it as a black box for this
scheme but you can just think of the of
the schemes that actually exist so there
are schemes that that do classical
homomorphic encryption and now we're
kind of going to bootstrap them to do
quantum homomorphic encryption for some
gates alright so first let's see what
happens if Alice would take our input
qubit sy encrypts it was a one-time pad
and then send it off to the cloud and
now just as an example let's see what
happens if the cloud wants to apply a
hotter market so if the cloud applies
the automark gate actually what comes
out because of these commutation rules
is
the atom are applied to the states with
a valid quantum wanting pads but the
problem here is that the key to the ones
in bed is not the same as before so it
used to be the key a B but now it's the
key B a and we can just you can just see
this by applying these rules we saw
earlier so the x and z swap swap value
and the same thing happens if we apply
the PGA Tour to C naught that we still
end up with a valid encryption of the of
the state but now with a key that was
wrong
so to fix this we're going to use the
second ingredient so after Alice
encrypts this qubit using the quantum
one-time pad she's now going to use the
classical homomorphic encryption scheme
to also encrypt these two bits that
define the quantum montón pet so this
red thing is just classical data just a
classical bit string in Alice her normal
laptop her normal computer and this blue
thing is a single quantum bits and now
if she sends both of those off to to the
cloud he can you know again as before
just applied how to mark to the quantum
bits so he just applies to Clifford to
the to the qubit but he can use this
classical morphic encryption scheme to
now also afterwards updates this
encrypted key of the one tempered so
it's still secure because he doesn't you
know from the perspective of the cloud
he just sees encrypted data but he can
use the homomorphic encryption scheme to
update it in the correct way and now if
when he sends it back to Alice Alice can
first use the key of the classical
encryption scheme to get back this
one-time pad and see you know to get
back the updated one team pad and then
use these updated ones and pets to
actually get back the results of this
computation and now I just did only one
qubit examples but just let's quickly go
through like a two qubit gates because
it's a little bit more complicated but
not much so if Alice has a two qubits I
she can you know use a quantum one-time
pad on both of the qubits
so which is just yeah just applying them
separately in either qubit and then she
can also you know encrypt the the keys
to this these two one-time pads send
those of and now the updates rule
associated to the cenotes it's maybe a
little bit more complicated than
hardware but it's still quite simple
it's just performing a binary XOR off of
one thing with you know one thing with
with one other thing so you know this is
a computation this can easily be handled
by a classical homomorphic encryption
scheme so we can use that to update and
the important thing here is that now the
computer can just contain the cloud
computer can continue this because the
form of this data it's you know he
started with classical encrypted
one-time pads and a quantum state with a
quantum want impact and after this
computation step it's again in the same
form so he can just apply this next
Clifford gate without any interaction
with Ellis and he can just continue this
indefinitely so this form having an
encrypted one-time pad and having a
quantum state encrypted with the with
that one-time pad this will be kind of
an invariant that that we will always
try to maintain and if we have
maintained this invariants we can then
go on to to perform a next state right
but this Clifford ski the Clifford
Clifford circuits are not universal
so we're going to have to add some gate
to make it Universal and a very popular
choice of to do this is the t gate
because so actually it's possible to add
pretty much any gate through you know to
this gate set to make it Universal but
the t gate has some nice properties of
its own which makes it a very appealing
choice and actually this has a very
simple form it's just it's just this
diagonal diagonal matrix and the
commutation rules so because it's
diagonal just commutes with is e but
when we look at T times X that equals
the phase gate times X times T so so
this is no longer the same form of
commutation rule as
help with with the Clifford group
because now there's this extra P gate
which is not a poly so for example if we
if we know too is if we would just try
to apply this T guide to something which
is encrypted with the one-time pad then
if the one-time pad X X part happens to
be zero then actually this T guide works
works fine because you just input it and
then the output is just the t gate
applied to the data but if the X part
happens to be one then there's this
extra phase gate and this phase gate is
from our perspective and error because
now we no longer have this invariant
that we just have our data encrypts it
with the quantum wants it bad we have
some extra extra gate that may or may
not be present and the class computer
also doesn't know whether it's present
or not because he actually doesn't know
this you know this first bit of the of
the ones in that so if this first bit of
the one's a bit we'll just call it a yes
you know we'll just call them a B so
we'll just call it a he doesn't know
that how to apply a correction only if
this bit equals one and earlier work
I'll try to get around this problem of
the T guides in different ways so so
this was the clever scheme and actually
the fact that I wrote computational
security just comes from the fact that
we use a classical or morphic encryption
scheme and the security of the classical
no more efficient scheme is based on
computational assumptions so that's why
the the quantum scheme is also based on
exactly the same computational
assumptions all right but so the other
the earlier work that tried to get rid
of this this unwanted face gate or try
to handle the T gate in some good way
was able to do it but then with the blow
up which killed badly with the number of
T gates so for example work by broadband
in Jaffrey was able to handle quantum
circuits with the constant T depth
because the size of the encryption
scaled exponentially in the number of
in the layers of tickets or they also
proposed a different scheme where the
complexity of the decryption function
scaled with the number of tickets which
made it kind of in between actual
compacts and for some circuits and not
quite compact for others and there was
also work by young Tony and Fitzsimmons
that was you know where the security
notion was a little bit different so
that information theater security
instead of computational assumptions
that were needed but that could also
only handle circuits with a constant
number of tickets so the scheme I'm
going to present now will actually be
able to handle quantum circuits of
polynomial size so I so the work we do
we'll still scale in some sense with the
number of tickets but now it scales
linearly so we can actually handle all
the all polynomial size circuits again
with computational assumptions all right
so now to pretend the new scheme so
we're going to build some gadgets we'll
call it that is able to correct this
error that we don't want so remember
that the so Ellis is going to build his
gadgets we when she generates the key
and then this gadget is able to take a
qubit that might have a piggy I'd
applied to it or not and then remove it
if it's present and then also you know
this will also involve updating the
classical key in some case and from the
perspective of clouds just remember that
the cloud doesn't know this bit a he
doesn't know whether to apply the spigot
or not and he will be the one that has
to do it because he's the one that's
performs the computation but he does
have an encrypted version of this bit a
so basically what he's so so just
remember that this bit a equals the
decryption where decryption is an actual
computation of you know and this
decryption depends on the private key
and this data that the cloud has so
properties of this of this gadget will
be so it should be efficiently
constructible of course
and and it will be unfortunately
destroyed every single use so we're
going to have to use a gadget for every
second but just just a single one
alright so now we're going to need some
ingredients from theoretical computer
science from complexity theory which is
called baricza's theorem so we're going
to take a small excursion and then apply
it back to see how we can use it to
construct the sketches and the main
object embarrasses theorem now is called
a permutation branching program and it's
a very simple model of computation so we
have some boolean function f that were
that we want to compute and we're going
to compute it using a list of
instructions so a program is just a list
of instructions and the instructions
consist of three parts
it consists of a label of a bits so for
example the first labels X I so it just
means go to the X input and look at the
if' bit and if this I Smith is equals
zero then this instruction instruction
evaluates to PI the first part and if
it's one it evaluates to Sigma I'll I'll
say what PI and Sigma are in a minute so
so that's just what happens we look at
the input and then just look at a single
bit at a time and then evaluate to
either pi or Sigma and this pi or Sigma
which you might guess from the name
permutation branching programs are
permutations so they're just
permutations in our case of five
elements so elements of of s5 the
symmetric group of five elements and
after evaluating all these instructions
we say that the outputs of a program
it's just applying all these
permutations whenever to the other just
just the normal group multiplication of
the of the permutations and then how
does this you know this multiplicative
function we say that if this
multiplication is the identity
permutation so if everything is back
where it started then then the function
equals zero
if it's some other fixed cycle then the
function equals one and so I'll give an
example of what such a such a of sexy
program in a second and we say that the
length of a program is just the number
of instructions so for example let's say
we we have a permutation branching
program of the or function so we know if
we've all seen the or function it's 1 if
x equals 1 or y equals 1 and we can
actually do it with the length 4 program
so the first instruction look at looks
at the bit X and then either is this
either evaluates to a cycle which maps 1
to 2 2 to 3 3 to 4 4 to 5 and 5 to 1 and
and if the bit equals 1 it evaluates the
identity and then it looks at a bit of Y
and evaluates to either the cycle or the
C looks at X again and it looks at Y
again so you may be we have to exit the
same bit multiple times but we just look
at X Y X Y so for example if we fail in
0 0
you know first we get then you know this
the simple cycle then the second
instruction looks at YC set 0 gets this
other cycle then we look at the first
bit again get this cycle and then look
at the second way to get this other
cycle and now you know of course it's
not easy to see instantly if to track
all these various graphical
representation of the permutations but I
colored one to make it a bit easier and
you can actually see that you know we
started with you know if you follow one
Maps first 2 2 then 2 4 then 2 3 then 2
1 again so and you know the other
elements also map to itself so this is
actually the identity permutation and
like we agreed before this means the
function equals 0 but we can also you
know look at the other inputs for
example x equals 0 y equals 1 so then we
evaluate the instructions again but now
you know now the Y instructions evaluate
to the second part and now if we track
this we see that actually it's not
identity but now you know we have that 1
maps to 4 like like
we say here and etc we met to some fixed
cycle and we you know we can continue
filming for the for the other two
options and see you know if you just
track track what happens you see that
this this branching program even though
it's a very simple object can compute
this function or well now you might be
curious what's you know what's the power
of these of these branching programs
these permutation branching programs
what can they do and actually so classic
results from from computer science is
Berenice theorem which was very
surprising at the time and it said that
you know these branching programs are
just introduced of polynomial length can
compute all functions in the function
class NC 1 so I I drew here some
complexity classes so the biggest one is
impede we all know and below that this P
polynomial tend computation so this L
here is computation that only have
logarithmic space memory and NC 1 the
function class I'm talking about is
still a bit smaller namely it's
logarithmic depth circuits but it
doesn't really matter what it is for us
right now but what mostly matters is
it's like a non trivial class of
functions this actually does have
interesting computations and one of the
interesting computations it has is
actually decryption functions of all
known classical homomorphic encryption
schemes and actually the the designers
of these classical homomorphic
encryption schemes really like their
decryption functions to be in NC 1 for 4
different technical reasons but for us
it now also helps a lot because we now
will be able to apply Bering Sea theorem
to these decryption functions
right so just remember what we were
trying to do we're going through back to
the gadget now we now we know axis
theorem so we want to build this gadget
that applies an infra state if this bit
equals one and now we have this you know
we know that this decrypt function has a
polynomial size wrenching program so
we're now going to build this gadget
that takes away the face gates if it's
present all right so now just first as
an overview what will be what will you
put in this gadget so you know and how
do we what do we do with the qubit when
we want to use it
all right the gadget will consist of a
few parts so the first part will we will
construct out of the permutation
branching program off the deep cube
function so remember that this decrypt
function so it did this decrypt function
on if we run it on the private key and
the encryption of this bit a then if
it's 0 we don't want to apply a face
gate I mean first phase gate and if it's
1 we do want to apply it in in first
phase gate but it being zero means that
this permutation branching program gives
the identity permutation so we're
actually going to you know in some way
represent this these paths in our
gadgets and then you know say use the
first element of this path and then this
first element of the path will be linked
to the first element of the output if
the bit a equals zero so we're going to
so so we're going to let the cubit trace
a pass-through thing using teleportation
and this you know and the end the path
will will go past that's the first thing
if we don't need to apply this
correction and it will go past one of
the others if we do need to apply one
and then you know just for technical
reasons we want to also extract this
qubit from this gadget afterwards
somehow so we're also going to reverse
all these steps and go back to the so we
can exits are our gadgets so I'll of
course explain what what I mean with
actually you know going through it
because of course no that doesn't mean
anything but I will explain how we go
through it so but for example in this
this case we didn't need to apply a
correction so the path will not go
through one of the inverse space gates
but you know for some other some other
value of this encrypted a this
permutation branching program will make
sure that we do go past one of the in
first face gets all right so now what do
I mean
like if qubit follows a path through
such a permutation branching program so
actually we're going to use
teleportation to do this so so this is
the branching program for this decrypt
function and remember that you know how
these things are linked up depends
alternately or we can just without the
loss of generality assume it's
alternately depends on a bit of the key
the the key that that Alice actually has
and then it will depend on a bit of this
encryption of a the thing that the cloud
computer has and that he wants to
decrypt in some way to you know know
whether not to apply this correction or
not and Alice will now create a PR pairs
depending on this permutation so she
will so for all these permutations you
will look at her bits and if it's zero
she will produce five EPR pairs per
mutants in the way you know according to
PI or and if it's one she will you know
create five EPR pairs the pen Bermuda's
according to Sigma and then when we're
going to use this gadget as a cloud he
will look at you know he would look at
this bits off this encrypted a and then
perform teleportation measurement so
Bell measurements all the things that
Alice will have given me so just to
recap so Alice is going to one by one
create the CPR pairs so she is going to
look at her as a kid creates a PR pairs
linked up according to this branching
program and now and of course now for
bookkeeping purposes she also needs to
encrypt the structure with the classical
morphic encryption scheme and now she
sends all of this off to the cloud and
now the cloud is you know it received
this this gadget and when he wants to
use it
he has his qubit he wants to he wants to
apply the correction to and he has his
classical information and now depending
on his classical information we will
teleport his qubits you know if first he
will perform a teleportation measurement
between his qubit and say the first EPR
have that Allison but afterwards he will
look at you know he will evaluate the
permutation branching program
instructions on his inputs your the ones
that he can evaluate get this
permutation back using this permutation
applied teleportation measurements and
in that way these qubits that he wants
the correct you know who wants the
correct will be teleported through this
you know pass all these EPR pairs
depending on you know depending on what
what he does and of course importantly
just to stress the path that this qubit
will take will go past this inverse
space get if the correction needs to be
applied and it will avoid it if no
correction needs to be applied and then
well then of course all these
teleportations also incur some
teleportation Corrections right if we
apply you know if we teleport the qubits
then then as part of this teleportation
you apply a random poly to these qubits
but luckily applying a random poly to
qubit just works very nicely with this
quantum one-time pad so we can now just
use the the informations alicent earlier
about the structure of the gadgets
encrypted together with the outcomes
that the server had and together
you know after Sochi the the class
computer can first apply all these
teleportation measurements and then you
know input these teleportation
measurements into another big classical
homomorphic computation and get back the
new key and now we're actually back to
our invariant that we wanted to get back
to so if there was a Facebook presence
it's gone and now we have this situation
again that we can continue our
computation right just a few words to
get some intuition about why is this
secure so well all quantum information
that we that we send is encrypted with a
quantum won't impact and the quantum
wants a patch is perfectly secure it's
it's like a very easy calculation if the
classical info is completely hidden well
but you might think what happens with
these you know this if er pairs that
Alice has constructed you know maybe
this tells something about you know
about the choices Alice made while
constructing them so actually Alice
doesn't really send epr pairs which
she's come to pick one of the four bell
states at random and since those along
instead and that is enough to hide the
structure completely as long as the
choice that she made you know which of
the four Bell States she picked is
completely hidden but now all classical
information that I mentioned here will
all be sent using the classical
homomorphic encryption scheme and just
so now if the classical mervich
encryption scheme is secure then this
scheme is also secure so we actually
don't need any other assumptions but we
just lean completely on the security of
the classical morphic encryption scheme
well or maybe to be able bit more
precise I guess we lean on the security
of the classical homomorphic encryption
scheme against quantum attackers but you
know if we if we do this then consummate
actors exist anyway circuits so that's
fine now and just a quick overview so
how does the ski how does the scheme
work in total
so the key generation is the first we
just generate the classical keys and
then Alice also generates a bunch of
gadgets
depending on how many computations the
cloud should be able to perform the
encryption is just applying the quantum
month impetus before and then including
critically classically encrypting the
path keys the evaluation procedure so
after after applying a Clifford Gates we
just do a the exact same thing as the
Clifford scheme we just update the the
case of the one-time pad but after
applying a ticket we we use this gadget
to correct all the stuff and then
actually the after after everything has
been done the state is still in the same
kind of form that we started with so
decryption is just just decrypt the key
of the one you know use classical
decryption to get the key back for the
one thing for the quantum states and
then decrypt a constant state so you
know what what might you use such a
scheme for well of course I hope that
there will be more applications soon but
just as a first first start so delegated
so this cream already performs delegated
computation in only two rounds so so
delegated computation is kind of a
related fields where where you want to
protocol where you can talk back and
forth with the server and let the server
cook compute something for you
well this you can also view this as a
protocol for delegated computed
computation which is very round
sufficient and it also has the the extra
well sometimes good property that that
the server doesn't even have to tell the
client what he's doing so I can just the
server now picks the pixi algorithm
so it's nice that so it's not ideal of
course that we have to generate these
gadgets but it's at least nice that we
can generate them on demand so if the
server says oh please give me some more
I want to be able to continue my my
computation then Alice can just generate
more and actually the the computations
that Alice has to do to generate them
are not so hard so all Alice has to be
able to do is generate EPR pairs or Bell
States and send them off so she doesn't
need any quantum memory she doesn't need
to do any other operations just
generating pairs of qubits and sending
them off so right so some one good
property if you work a little bit more
it's very easy to make an extension of
the scheme which also has circuit
privacy so that means that after alice
does her encryption she has no way of
knowing at all what what computation was
applied to it except of course you know
what the output of the computation was
so we know what's next what can we do
now to to extend the scheme so of course
the most obvious thing is this is we
call this level
quantum fully homomorphic encryption
because that's at key generation time or
at least at the quick time we have to
pick the amount so the an upper bound to
the computation size so even though this
upper bound is a polynomial size circuit
it would it would be nicer if if you
don't have an upper bound at all so the
not a good next step would be to add
verification so now of course part of
homomorphic encryption is that the cloud
computer has some choice in what what
computation to apply he doesn't have to
tell LS what he's going to do beforehand
but for some applications it might be
very nice if afterwards the server can
prove that that he did the certain thing
and in the classical case homomorphic
encryption is is a key ingredient in
building operation which is another
cryptographic primitive
it's a very natural thing to try to
build quantum quantum obfuscation of
obfuscation of quantum circuits now now
we that we have a scheme of homomorphic
encryption and see whether the
techniques of the classical worlds also
translate to the quantum world in this
case and that was it thank you
[Applause]
anyways so we have plenty of time for
questions please tell Jeff Lori as much
as possible
thank you so classical morphix schemes
are malleable by definition what about
your quantum scheme so I guess they
they're also I mean like I guess this is
also by definition malvo it's like I
mean the thing that you want actually is
that that someone else is able to change
your your data so I think it should be
the same here although this verification
might might change it a little bit right
so
well I guess I'm not entirely sure what
it means to have a non malleable
homomorphic encryption scheme because
the homomorphic part really means that
you want something else to to perform a
computation so I actually have two
questions so the first one I'm sorry if
you said this the assumption is that the
cloud has to follow the protocol or can
he deviate from the protocol well he can
the security so the security in the
sense of privacy of the data still holds
if the cloud deviates from the protocol
so all we say is that so
why the cloud is not even really a part
of the security definition it's just
ellis encrypts the stuff and then you
just have this this you know bunch of
quantum data in classical data and then
you know anyone who sees this bunch of
data I should it should be secure
against anyone who sees this including
the cloud because the cloud doesn't know
anything more than any observer at all
so and then the second question was so
if I'm understanding correctly Alice has
to know kind of what the classical
encryption of the key is in order to do
this gadget yeah and then so so know it
knows what it will be at the time that
this thus calculus is performed well she
know well she doesn't really know the
encryption of the sort of person who
generates the gadget needs to know the
the key of the classical scheme is
that's what you mean yeah but that that
kind of changes I mean but it needs he
it seemed it seemed to me I mean if I'm
if I'm understanding correctly I might
not have that he needed to know actually
the ciphertext okay no so she doesn't
need to notice I I mean of course I do
know the length of the ciphertext but so
this this branching program say
alternately depends on things Alice
knows and thinks the cloud knows so
Ellis and you know to construct this
branching program you don't need to know
the the company you know you don't need
to know the ciphertext at all like you
need to know the ciphertext to
- then run it and know you know do I
apply this permutation or the other one
but to construct to come up with this
list of instructions you I guess all you
need to know is like the key length but
you don't need to know the the cipher
text yet you only need to know the
cipher text to use it and the cloud
knows the cipher text so he uses those
but and then potentially creates four
gadgets so that kind of all of the
encryptions of zero do one thing and all
of the encryptions of the one to the
other
yes basically yes so like whenever
whenever you use this gadget with an
encryption of zero but of mice
you know this encryption of zero might
have some randomness in it for example
there might be lots of encryptions of
zero then all of them will you know
well a Christian of zero actually then
it will not do anything with the cubit
and if it's an encryption of one it will
apply to space gates any other questions
so so Alice has to send a number of EPR
pairs based on her key right yes but
what happens is the scheme robust to
errors on Alice's side in those EPR
pairs right to those GPRS pairs have to
be perfect or can the scheme account for
errors on Alice's side right that's a
good question so what I mean if it's
like tiny errors of course it should be
realistic tiny errors but actually it is
the case that say if one of the EPR
pairs is not an EPR peridot
you know perhaps just two qubits in the
product side then you know with
probability one fifth I guess because
you know it might not the path might not
encounter that one but if the path goes
through that one you will probably you
know this will break so so actually if
the scheme like this is not it's not
that robust to sending you know if Alice
messes up its sending any PRP I guess it
might be still possible to put error
correction on top of it like you can put
error correction on top of any
computation just I have a one quick
question related to this so but the
error on the EPR pairs does that only
affect or crack knees or is there any
effect on the security as well well if
this okay so what Ellison's should be
completely I mean it should look
completely mixed against someone who
doesn't know the information so well I
mean it depends on what you mean with
eridan right of course if the error is
accidentally sent you sent my key over
then so it's but if the error is
independent of the of this key of the
classical data then that should be fine
so then there's no problem there how
does this scheme hide how does this
scheme compare to the blind quantum
computation schemes of broadband
Fitzsimmons in Keshava right so the
blind the task in blind computation is a
it's a bit different because in the I
guess in the blind computation case then
alice is the one that chooses what to do
you show chooses the computation and now
we're talking about the case where where
the clouds is the one that knows the
program that he wants to apply so that
makes it makes it different and also
there I think that usually the blind
computation schemes have some some way
of interacting so it's like an
interactive protocol but
in our case it's just you know encrypt
send it off and then eventually you get
back back what you want so that my might
sometimes be easier if you want to use
it as a primitive to build something
else so just a quick comment to repeat
what Lauren was answering about the
noise issue so I think what you need to
do is just to perform the homomorphic
computation on the error corrections air
corrected circuit so if there is noise
you do the error correction on the noise
regularly and then there is this new
circuit that is simulating then using
noisy gates to simulate the noise noise
the circuit then you perform the entire
foreign circuit with the homomorphic
encryption then I think all the problem
will be resolved okay thanks the other
question
how does Alice determine how many
gadgets she needs to construct right so
okay so this is why it's not you know
this was like the first point of my
future work right it's not there's this
level two quantifier so it's like so I
guess it depends on the on the
application so sometimes when you use it
as a primitive for something else you
might actually have a good upper bounds
to the the size the polynomial size
circuit you want to perform but but in
general I guess it depends on the
application and sometimes so you don't
necessarily need to construct them while
encrypting so you might if if you have a
setting where interactive protocols are
fine which is the case for some you know
for some cloud computing applications
then she might have also construct them
on demand didn't sure if it just says
okay you know my computation will take a
bit longer than expected just give me
some some more of these these EPR pairs
that I can use to continue
so possibly like maybe I just missed
this but you said the security of this
rests on the security of the classical
homomorphic scheme and but in the table
in the overview you said that you had
comm information theoretic security or
do they get that wrong or is it
computational if it's there I shouldn't
be you know it should have said I mean I
think it said computational okay that
was a mistake
like the rest on the computational
security of the other scheme okay so
then my follow-up question can you use
the so there was a result by fit Simon's
Airtel where they managed to get
information theoretic security is there
any hope of boosting two informations
register using those techniques I don't
think so because I think it's actually
so I think that also uh no I don't think
so I think there are information theater
security for for general size circuits
will be will be very hard and it doesn't
scale directly here like actually we do
put some work some actual work in this
classical amorphic encryption scheme
it's not that's really what to do and it
is known also that that information is
theoretic classical homomorphic
encryption schemes do not exist in
general so you know we cannot say we
hope that someday one of those will be
found and then we can plug it in the
thing we can take one last quick
question
well if there isn't let's thank our
speaker again
[Applause]
[Music]